[Music]
is this everybody's first non-zoom
interview
isn't this fabulous
welcome
zola is the is an adaptation of the
wildly popular twitter thread by a 19
year old woman detailing her harrowing
adventure
with a fast friend uh uh too long it's
too long it's not working sorry
this is this is our writing process
write something that you give a shit
about and that sounds really
easy it's
harder than it seems just because it's
been trained out of us but it's i think
something that you can kind of naturally
find if you just
you know don't have any friends and
stuff so just like
so just don't have friends i was writing
a story about somebody rediscovering
their love and and um it was in a way a
way of telling myself that i could do
what i loved again this is a movie about
someone's unconscious
i think life is full of trippy magic
actually
stone cold sober when you're in touch
with like something alive
and when i thought of the idea for the
movie i thought of the first scene and i
thought of the last shot that's what i
thought of immediately and then i was
like okay let's earn it there's like
nothing that separates the screenwriters
in the room from any of the people lit
up here it's about the work it's about
working really hard and i think the
industry like loves to create a certain
mystique that makes people feel that
that is so totally inaccessible and the
reality is is that it just isn't
we need stories and we need voices
so never let yours get squashed